next week thing is test your commitment
so you write down all the ideas that you
you've really got that 16 or higher so
the ones that you're excited about then
I want you to go commit to doing some
research on it now commit to
understanding the lifestyle that goes
with running that type of business and
you you want to do at least a half an
hour research on the internet and at
least one trip to the library bookstore
and this sheet here is just saying that
you have to commit you put check mark
for each one check check that commit to
doing it and then you check when it's
done and this is important and I want
you to go and actually go to a store or
library to research and not just do it
online it's important because you're
you're building momentum for your idea
so you're taking that time out of your
day to go to the bookstore and do a
little bit of research on that business
opportunity and what the last I would be
like and see if it's something that
still is a few it may sound interesting
in our head but until you're going out
to learn about it it may not be as
exciting anymore so you want actually
going and do that if you can't follow
through in that commitment then you're
probably not going to be a great
entrepreneur in that industry right if
you if you wrote down some great ideas
but you're not willing to go up to the
library and read a book then you're
probably not going to have the
commitment to be able to launch a
successful company out so the internet
research a little bit easier library
requires a little more commitment to
encourage you to go out and do it and
then the ones that you actually have
gone and done you move those to the
final list as potential opportunities to
start a business off the last list here
is you test your commitment and what
you'll find is as you do research on
different ideas some of them are going
to be ones that really speak to you that
are really exciting and that you kind of
get lost in and I found this was for me
with famous entrepreneur so my website
is really based around famous
entrepreneur stories that's how I
started it and I found that when I was
starting my business I could consume so
many anything with entrepreneur of
stories I loved hearing about the
success of motivated me gave me ideas to
grow my business and it just consumed me
so if they've only spending half an hour
on internet research was ridiculous I
spent hours and hours hours hours doing
it so I found that to be a
extremely motivated me so you want to
look at how much time you can spend
doing all of those how much time did you
spend online research in each idea how
much time did you spend at the library
of the bookstore and add all that up and
then you're going to end up seeing that
some of the ideas just hit the bare
minimum right you just did it because I
told you to do order because you thought
it was an interesting idea but you
didn't actually go and try and do a lot
more go way above expectations and
you'll find it'll be a big separation on
this list some of them you're going to
spend a lot of time doing and some of
them you won't now think as an
entrepreneur if you're just doing a bare
minimum you're probably not going to
have a lot of success right
entrepreneurship is fun and awesome and
very rewarding but it's also a lot of
hard work and so you can't just do the
bare minimum you have to be able to be
able to invest a lot of time into it so
look at your top ideas and rank them by
how much time you actually spent
researching it and if you see one two or
three of them really above all the other
ones those are the areas that you want
to focus on so hopefully that helps walk
you through how to identify your passion
and then try to figure out what business
opportunity you might be most interested
in and be able to build around I'll
answer questions again as a comer at the
end if you have more because I know a
lot of people are struggling with that
how to find a passion the next thing is
work to learn started girl number two
before you start your business I go try
to get some actual experience in the
field that you're interested in so you
know what you want to be an internet
marketer go work with someone who goes
into the mark you want to be a carpenter
go work with somebody who is a carpenter
right now if you haven't started your
business yet you're you're in a job so
why not work in something that you can
learn about so you can become a better
entrepreneur at some point in the future
so you're going to be working anyway you
might as well work to be able to gain
experience for starters in your business
as you're doing it I wouldn't worry so
much about the money yes you need to
make some money to be able to you know
support yourself and you know pay all
your bills but the more important thing
here is the experience you want to try
to take on as many projects as you can
try to get a job where you can work with
the CEO or the the entrepreneur
themselves so
that you can learn directly what they're
going through if you're a web designer
and you want to set your own web design
company if you're already working at a
web design company try not to just do
the web design because an entrepreneur
is more than just being you know one
specific task try to work with the
entrepreneur and offer to take on more
responsibilities and get more involved
you'll be able to learn way more by how
to start a company by getting that
hands-on experience now if you're ready
have a job and you don't want to leave
it to try something new you have some
security I know it can be tough if you
you've already been working somewhere
for ten years it's hard to leave it and
take an internship job somewhere else do
it part time weekend ends evenings find
a company that you can work for at a you
know whatever rate doesn't matter you
want the experience and the thing here
is you're going to take your watch
University going to entrepreneur
university and you're getting paid to do
it right you're not having to pay for
the opportunity to learn they're paying
you a salary right sis you're helping
them you can have some only evenings or
weekends you're getting paid to learn
and take on as many projects as you can
and then you'll be able to have a lot
more success in a knowing it is right
for you right you may you may start this
thing you'll get a part-time job with
this company and realize you know what I
I do not want to be a web designer I do
not want to be a carpenter or whatever
it is and that's great because you've
learned on somebody else's dying you
haven't gone in and spent thousands of
dollars or whatever it is and quit your
job to start this business and then
realize that it wasn't for you so you
want to be able to get that hands-on
experience figured if it's for you or
not and then also build up some contacts
and build up some experience that when
you do go out and launch a business
you're really ready to go and do it so
that's work tools learns a quick quote
from a robert kiyosaki who's the rich
dad poor dad work to learn don't work
for money look for jobs that can help
you develop the skills systems of people
rather than just pay you well and you're
gonna I know mine is important you're
going to make money you're going to make
money as an entrepreneur that's the
payday that's the bigger payday down the
road right now you got to get your
experience if you haven't actually
started business before and another
quick quote from Ben Franklin many
empties his purse into his head no man
can take it away from him an investment
in knowledge always pays the best
interest
moving on so set up real number three
start part-time this is really important
as well a lot of people think to start a
business they have to quit their job and
jump in full time and I think you can
start it on a part-time basis very
easily so if you already have your
full-time job and I hopefully senior
industry if it's not you're doing
something else to learn but then start
your business on the side and commit
time to it every day even if it's half
an hour a day 15 minutes that they find
the chunk of time every day to do
something to move your business forward
it's a lot less risk so you already have
your income coming in from your job and
now here's an opportunity to make a
little bit more if you can figure out at
what point you want to leave your job to
focus on your business a lot of people
say and once I'm making the same income
for my business as am from my job then
I'm going to quit or if I'm making fifty
percent I'm gonna quit who'd exam for my
wife she was she right now runs the
largest salsa dance for geeky people had
a sauce salsa dance in in maybe north
will your how to do it and she started
doing it as a part-time hobby she was
working at the Marriott and had a really
great was salsa dancing and just fell in
love with it and she took the
opportunity to start her own business
and thought maybe I'm gonna earn I what
I was doing I can marry but that's okay
because I'm doing something I'm really
passionate about so that opportunity
turned into a huge business for her and
she now has ten instructors and fifty
people who helped her and built a huge
business as a result of it so start
part-time you're much more likely to
keep it going if you're still earning
some kind of money coming in but you
have to make sure that you're doing
something every day to make sure that
business is growing so a quick quote
from Alan Sugar was from from Britain
and he's on that the artist version in
Britain start small start with your own
money you don't need to go out and raise
a ton of venture capital you don't need
to go out and get you know millions on
board before you start your business
start really small and
start part time and just make sure hey
Evan in the right business go back to
step salon and do something that you're
passionate up you should come home if
you're working out and say I can't wait
to go and spend time working on my
business huh yep we lost your audio
there for a little bit connection and
you guys hear me I can hear you we just
awaiting a little fuzzy yeah just for a
little bit yep ok now it's guy yet looks
like we're good yeah and sure shireen
was saying go a little slower I guess
maybe she's taken notes um but she she
thinks you might be going a tad fast so
ok uh are you excited but we'll go we'll
slow it down a little bit it's hard to
paste it because we think it's when you
can't see anybody you can't see their
people's reaction so and also we are
recording this so hopefully we can get
this up to you within a few days but you
know if you do miss anything please you
know don't worry about it we do have
questions at the end and we're recording
this too so um you know that's just to
make sure that they know that all right
ok you Evan great thank you yeah and
thanks Carl for going to keeping us on
track there